Boy math is reading that 97% of women have been sexually harassed,
but not knowing a single person who's sexually harassed anyone.
Boy math is thinking that a woman's vagina
stretches if she has sex with 50 different people once,
but not if she has sex with one person 50 times.
Boy math is accusing women of being gold diggers
whilst simultaneously being dependent on women's unpaid labour.
Boy Math is telling women with high body counts they're worthless
and continuously asking them what they bring to the table,
whilst also complaining about the male loneliness epidemic.
Boy Mouth is banging on about sex work not being a real job
but then also funding the industry.